Muhammad Ershad ro Hinch a Muslim
survived being shot by Myanmar's army we
weren't even outside in the road when it
happened we'd stayed inside in our homes
soldiers burst into our houses and shot
at us indiscriminately an estimated
90,000 drew Hendra Muslims have fled
into this Bangladeshi border region the
UN says Myanmar's army may be committing
ethnic cleansing hospitals are
struggling to cope
for coming with diverse injuries
multiple injuries and most of them
almost all of them financially
1.1 million Roja live in Myanmar where
they are denied citizenship and have
long complained of persecution at the
hands of both militant Buddhists and the
army the conflict has been roiling
Myanmar's diplomatic relations Myanmar s
de facto leader Aung San su Chi has not
commented this despite pressure from
Indonesia's foreign minister
Myanmar's actions have been condemned by
Muslim leaders and protests have sprung
up around the world some have turned
violent a petrol bomb was thrown at the
Myanmar embassy in Jakarta